[Music]
all right daniel's with us in new york
city hi daniel welcome to the ramsey
show
hey guys what's going on
hey how can we help sure
hi okay so my question is my question is
basically and don't get mad at me dave
but
i think i want to lease a car
and i know you're not supposed to lease
a car
supposed to buy a used one in cash
but
i think i can afford to lease a car and
i think it's the better move for me
like i'm curious what you have to say on
that
well you kind of know what i'm gonna say
obviously don't you
yeah but maybe um well daniel i think
this is where you lay out your case for
dave you know what he's gonna say so why
do you think it's a better deal than
buying a used car okay good idea
right so why i think is because
i could let's say by uh try to find a
reliable used car for like a 10 or 15
000
but i personally wouldn't feel
comfortable driving that around
in terms of reliability because for work
i'm driving sometimes two hours in the
middle of nowhere um i just don't want
to you know risk any finger i want to
have
a new car and 10 years from now i don't
want to be driving
a 10 year old car
okay so that's that's why for me
that's why i think and i don't have in
your how old
i'm 23. and your house your income is
what
i make uh 120. okay good for you how
many miles you putting on that car
i would probably keep within the ten
thousand miles
a year not if you're driving
a day that's where i had a problem with
your math are you driving four miles an
hour no but it's not it's not every day
i work for myself so i'm more i'm not
working every day
dude you're in prison with those lease
miles but okay so wait a minute you
can't have it both ways okay you can't
have it i drive two and a half miles a
day i drive two and a half hours every
day so i need a reliable car but wait a
minute no i don't drive two and a half
hours a day i only drive 10 000 miles a
year so i don't need a reliable car
occasionally i drive two and a half
hours
yeah frequently okay well not frequently
over 10 000 miles
the occasional frequency
it doesn't add up you can't daniel you
can't have it both ways the math doesn't
work in your discussion okay
so here's the thing here's the thing
here's the thing yeah broke people drive
new cars
there's two people that drive brand new
cars
mega millionaires
and broke people these are the only two
people the vast majority of new cars are
broke people because they go down in
value like a rock
you're either going to put the miles on
this fleece car and you're going to blow
the lease up or you're not going to put
the miles on it and it's going to eat
you alive
you can do what you want to do you call
me there's no possible way i'm going to
tell a 23 year old is smart enough to
make 120 000 to go fleece a stupid car